good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight they keep trying to stop Trump
and they keep failing late tonight the
Minnesota Supreme Court dismissed a
lawsuit that would have kept the former
president off the ballot entirely that
was based on a totally bogus claim that
he's disqualified from being president
under the 14th Amendment it's just not
going to work so what's next in their
bag of dirty tricks to try to stop this
guy well we're going to discuss it a
little later but first what happened and
what's next that's the focus of
tonight's
angle no getting around it Republicans
were once again disappointed last night
big weed and big abortion won in Ohio
the GOP lost its dream of taking control
of the Virginia state house and the
incumbent Democrat in Kentucky Andy
Basher he won now naturally Democrats
are leaping to the conclusion that Biden
emerges as Superman
it was a significant victory for
Democrats and it couldn't come at a
better time for them as there is
tremendous anxiety about President
Biden's bid for reelection last night is
indicative that the coalitions are
actually strong boom once again Joe
Biden's
underestimated yeah Joe now wait
listening to that crowd you think that
Biden was out there week after week
vigorously campaigning Virginia and Ohio
Kentucky forget super man he's more like
Kryptonite one of the things I convinced
president when I was vice president I
convinced the president to
do that's the amtr behind him now in a
Washington Post poll Biden's approval in
Virginia is at a lame
43% meanwhile in the same survey
Republican Governor Glenn yin's approval
is at
54% also there were some genuinely
positive trends for the GOP in Virginia
Republicans won 13 districts that
President Biden won in 2020 Republicans
won seven districts where the
Congressional Democratic candidate won
in
2022 and like look in a state that Biden
carried by what 10 points just three
years ago Republicans came within just a
few thousand votes of winning majorities
in both legislative Chambers out of
roughly 2.3 million votes cast so do
they wish they did better of course but
is it a total disaster far from it and
in Kentucky let's face this no one was
going to beat Basher but at one point
polling showed Daniel Cameron down
double digits he came within about what
five percentage points it's not bad
given the power of the Basher family
name plus the good news is that all
other major Statewide offices in
Kentucky went big for republicans and
then there was Mississippi where
Democrats got their hopes up that Elvis
Presley's cousin would unseat incumbent
conservative Tate Reeves but they were
All Shook Up because it didn't happen
Reeves won Republicans even managed to
snag a few victories in New York where
Republican Ed promain flip Long Island
suffk County Executive seat we continue
to chip away at the Democrat Party there
so keep it up so everyone's asking me
today and run into them what lessons we
take from this what do we do next well
first micro targeting voters matters
Democrats knew that suburbanites in
Virginia and Ohio would turn out for the
abortion issue they were right almost
every Democrat ad that I saw in Virginia
over the last what 90 days or so was
about abortion it was nothing about how
great the economy is under Biden or the
Democrats so Democrat Consultants stuck
to that issue because it worked in the
midterms and with abortion front and
center the parental rights issue that
work for yunan back in 2021 kind of got
drowned out this time Democrats were
ready and by election day the issue was
no longer about protecting our kids it
was about keeping Nazis off the school
board again it's time to recognize that
the suburbs are increasingly left
leaning on the cultural issues plus the
Democrats are able to out raise outspend
and better frame these issues than
Republicans and I know now you're
hearing this you're saying okay so now
what
with with these Dynamics at play how can
conservatives still win well my answer
is of course they can win mostly last
night's results confirm what we've been
saying all along the GOP must continue
to harvest voters from where they are
for the GOP which is among workingclass
multiethnic voters right now we Face a
coalition of upper class voters big
business and far-left culture Warriors
that's not changing anytime soon look a
few decades ago certainly back in the
80s it wasn't This Way businesses
weren't you know they were anti-soviet
and they were far more pro-american than
prog globalization the left was pretty
much relegated to college campuses and a
few places like San Francisco Greenwich
Village and so forth Rich Americans also
tended to be more politically pragmatic
back then but that's pretty much changed
but the views of most workingclass
voters have not changed which is why
it's key that we follow the strategy
that Trump began with economic growth
stuff like lower gas prices peace
through strength elect Democrats and
you're going to get more inflation more
exploding migrant populations and more
war period that kind of message wins and
will prove the overly confident
Democrats wrong since we've had Joe
Biden at the top of the ticket they
Democrats won the presidency um they did
fantastically well in 2022 now in 2023
far exceeding expectations basically
everything they could have won they then
why are Democrats still so worried
exactly even when Democrats are doing
great under Joe Biden all they want to
do is
panic panic are the Americans doing
great Panic ex is exactly what so many
American families are feeling now
because of Joe Biden and conservatives
need to Galvanize those people and these
voters aren't just white men living
outside the old manufacturing hubs in
places like akan Ohio Burlington Vermont
they're black and they're brown too and
new immigrants as well who came here for
a better life for their children not
what they're experiencing today so the
message might be when we're back in
control you'll be able to keep your gas
powered car and fill it with gas that
you can actually afford when we win
we'll enforce our own border before we
spend billions trying to enforce other
country's borders we'll take power away
from government bureaucrats and give it
back to you hardworking Americans who
just want a fair
shot next year's election should be
about common sense we have it Democrats
have none so they're celebrating Ohio's
ballot initiatives but those issues
didn't stop JD Vance from winning last
year did they and another reason by the
way to believe that Democrats are
unjustifiably confident in Biden's 2024
prospects look no further than comments
made by the matriarch of corruption
herself Hillary Clint
Barack Obama was behind at this point in
his reelection my husband was behind at
this point in his reelection Joe Biden
uh is not only uh proved that he's done
a good job but look at the alternative
and and look at what we would face as a
country and I think the election results
yesterday should be very good news for
President Biden look at what would face
as a country peace prosperity and a
closed border yes secretary bleach bit
is actually trying to to convince us
that Biden's political skills are on par
with Obama's and Clinton's yeah the fact
is beyond the Republicans being
outmaneuvered on the social issues they
were outspent in all of these races as
well so is there a plan I mean does
anyone have a plan for how to turn that
around in 2024 it does not seem like it
and the other point is as always the
media was egregiously pro-abortion and
pro marijuana and its coverage obviously
we know that's not going to change so
again we must accept these facts and
pivot we have to build on the success
that Trump DeSantis Greg Abbott in Texas
and a lot of other great Governors have
found their policies appealed to
Republicans and Independence and
open-minded Democrats including to
Hispanics and even more African-American
men so is next year going to be an
uphill battle I'm not trying to shy away
from that it is but Republicans can win
after all they control about half of the
country and their policies make life
better for working people why else would
76% of the country on the Monday poll
just released by The New York Times say
we're going in the wrong direction and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else